averigüemos la geometría de la molécula
de metano usando la teoría de spr por
sus siglas en inglés también conocida
como teoría de erc y pp lo primero que
haremos es dibujar la estructura de
puntos de lewis para mostrar los
electrones de valencia en el metano el
carbono se encuentra en el grupo 4 de la
tabla periódica así que tiene 4
electrones de valencia y el hidrógeno
tiene un electrón de valencia y como
tenemos 4 hidrógenos 1 por 4 + 4 es
igual a 8 electrones de valencia
entonces dibujemos el carbono al centro
que está unido a 4 hidrógenos
ahora ya pusimos 8 electrones 246
y 8 el carbono ha completado su octeto
ahora lo siguiente que necesitamos es
contar el número de nubes electrónicas o
nubes de electrones que rodean al átomo
central recuerden que las nubes
electrónicas son regiones en las que hay
densidad electrónica así que podemos
considerar a los enlaces como nubes
electrónicas aquí tenemos una por acá
tenemos otra esta sería otra y
finalmente ésta es otra tenemos cuatro
nubes electrónicas rodeando al átomo
central
el siguiente paso es predecir la
geometría de las nubes electrónicas que
rodean al átomo central la teoría de spr
dice que los electrones de valencia se
repelen porque están cargados
negativamente y por lo tanto tratarán de
estar lo más lejos posible entre ellos
se forma algo parecido a un tetraedro
cuatro nubes electrónicas forman una
geometría tetra erika que se ve así
esta es una figura que tiene cuatro
caras triangulares y observen que las
esquinas del tetraedro son como los
hidrógenos que tenemos en la molécula
espero que puedan verlo entonces una vez
que sabemos cuál es la geometría que
forman las nubes electrónicas que se
encuentran alrededor del átomo central
el cuarto paso es ignorar cualquier par
de electrones libres alrededor del átomo
central aunque en este caso no tenemos
electrones libres así que la geometría
de la molécula es la misma geometría de
las nubes electrónicas el metano es una
molécula tetrabrik
muy bien ahora en términos del ángulo de
enlace el ángulo que existe entre los
enlaces de una molécula con geometría te
trae drica este ciento 9.5 grados esto
es lo máximo que los electrones se
pueden alejar entre ellos además ciento
9.5 grados es el ángulo ideal entre
enlaces para una molécula con geometría
te trae drica hagamos otra tenemos
amoniaco nh3 y lo primero que
necesitamos es dibujar la estructura
para eso veamos cuáles son los
electrones de valencia como el nitrógeno
se encuentra en el grupo 5 tenemos 5
electrones de valencia y como el
hidrógeno se encuentra en el grupo 1
pero tenemos 3 hidrógenos 1 por 3 + 5
nuevamente tenemos 8 electrones de
valencia
vamos a poner nuestro nitrógeno en el
centro que está unido a tres hidrógenos
contemos los electrones tenemos 2 4 y 6
6 electrones 8 menos 6 es igual a 2 así
que nos falta colocar 2 electrones que
no los podemos poner en los hidrógenos
porque todos ya tienen 12 electrones a
su alrededor pero si los podemos poner
en el átomo central el nitrógeno
ahí está veamos nuevamente cuáles son
los pasos después de dibujar la
estructura de puntos hay que contar las
nubes electrónicas que rodean al átomo
central es decir hay que identificar las
regiones en donde hay densidad
electrónica entonces aquí tenemos una
nube electrónica
aquí tenemos otra por acá tenemos otra
y este par de electrones libres también
cuentan como una nube de electrones
porque también es una región con
densidad de electrónica entonces
nuevamente tenemos cuatro nubes
electrónicas y forman una geometría
tetra hedrick a sí redibuja mos la
molécula de amoniaco tenemos a los tres
hidrógenos hacia abajo y hacia arriba
tenemos el par de electrones libres así
es como se ve la molécula cuando las
nubes electrónicas forman una geometría
tetra erika ahora regresemos a los pasos
en el paso tres pre decimos que la
geometría que forman las nubes
electrónicas que se encuentran alrededor
del átomo central este trae drica pero
para predecir la geometría de la
molécula hay que ignorar cualquier par
de electrones libres entonces en la
molécula de amoniaco necesitamos ignorar
parte de electrones libres en el
nitrógeno y solo tomaremos en cuenta la
parte de abajo observen que tenemos algo
parecido a una pirámide a esta geometría
se le conoce como piramidal trígono
piramidal
trigo na
entonces aun cuando las nubes
electrónicas forman una geometría tetra
hedrick a la geometría de la molécula es
piramidal tribunal porque no se toma en
cuenta el par de electrones libres por
otro lado en términos del ángulo de
enlace este par de electrones libres en
el nitrógeno ocupan más espacio que los
electrones que forman un enlace y por
eso los electrones libres repelen un
poco más a estos electrones así que el
ángulo será un poco más pequeño que el
ángulo de ciento 9.5 grados que vimos en
la geometría tetra erika el ángulo de
enlace entre estos átomos es de
aproximadamente 107 grados
este es el ángulo para la geometría
piramidal trigon al muy bien hagamos uno
más ahora con la molécula de agua
aquí tenemos h2o
y para seguir los pasos sabemos que el
hidrógeno se encuentra en el grupo 1 y
tenemos 2 también sabemos que el oxígeno
se encuentra en el grupo 6 entonces 6 +
2 es igual a 8 electrones de valencia y
esta vez pongamos al oxígeno en el
centro que está unido a dos hidrógenos
contemos los electrones de valencia
aquí tenemos 2 y 4 entonces 8 menos 4
nos falta colocar 4 electrones de
valencia que no podemos poner en los
hidrógenos porque ya están felices con 2
electrones así que los pondremos en
nuestro átomo central tenemos dos pares
de electrones libres en el oxígeno
finalmente hemos colocado los 8
electrones de valencia el siguiente paso
es contar las nubes electrónicas que se
encuentran alrededor
el átomo central así que tenemos una dos
y este par de electrones libres también
cuenta al igual que este entonces
tenemos cuatro nubes electrónicas en
total que buscarán formar una geometría
tetra erika quieren estar lo más lejos
posible
sin embargo redibujar en la molécula de
agua en este caso tenemos dos pares de
electrones libres y recordemos que los
electrones libres ocupan más espacio que
los electrones que forman un enlace
provocando que el ángulo de enlace sea
más pequeño e incluso más pequeño que
107 grados este ángulo es de
aproximadamente ciento 4.5 grados y
finalmente para la geometría de la
molécula las nubes electrónicas forman
una geometría detrae briqa pero la
geometría de la molécula es
ya que no se toman en cuenta los pares
de electrones libres si analizamos la
geometría sin tomar en cuenta los
electrones libres nos queda así se
conoce como geometría angular angular y
el ángulo de enlace en esta geometría es
de aproximadamente ciento 4.5 grados
estos son algunos ejemplos que tienen
cuatro nubes electrónicas y hablamos
tanto de la geometría como de los
ángulos de enlace